[Musique]
comme tous les mardis mélanie poquet
nous a rejoint un plateau bonsoir votre
coup de coeur de la semaine fait
souffler un vent de liberté de par sa
thématique mais aussi par les
comédiennes qui sont sur scène alors il
s'agit de année ça ludivine shirin dana
lorraine à bip
inès maureen yasmina dix jeunes femmes
leur point commun elles sont toutes
issues de quartiers populaires et sont
novices flammes et leur première scène
le metteur en scène
ahmed madani poursuit sa recherche
artistique avec des jeunes nés de
parents immigrés certains sont d'origine
algérienne ivoirienne ou encore créole
j'ai pas une histoire déchirante à vous
raconter
voyez le genre de truc je porte un lourd
fardeau
nous sommes issus d'un peuple qui a
beaucoup souffert
la tragique histoire de ma mère la
tragique histoire de mon père si pour
toi être un homme c'est de frapper une
femme alors frappe moi mais ma mère elle
poussait toujours à l'école
inès plénier moi je veux que mes enfants
aillent à l'école
mon père m'a sous les avec barry white
est ce qui fait que ça marche mélanie
c'est que les comédiennes jouent en fait
leur propre rôle dans vos rôles elle se
confiait au public leur histoire celle
de leur famille celle de leur quotidien
le public entre ainsi dans l'intimé
flamme est en fait le deuxième volet
d'une trilogie km madani a nommé face à
leur destin lors le premier volet le
signe en 2012 avec des jeunes hommes du
val fourré ça s'appelait illuminations
ahmed madani mêlant général fiction et
réalité est là aussi tout par des
comédiennes sensible le principe était
de ne pas commencer à écrire un seul mot
avant que l'équipe soit rassemblée sur
le sur le plateau et j'ai travaillé
pendant deux ans en immersion on
rencontre en deux jeunes femmes en leur
posant des questions qu'elle était
capable de me livrer de 2,7 choses
intimes en elle et de la deûle à
partager ensuite avec les spectateurs
alors ahmed madani a rencontré des
centaines de jeunes femmes dix d'entre
elles ont accepté de monter sur scène
elle parle donc mais elle chante aussi
elle mime elle danse ce qui en ressort
c'est surtout l'honnêteté de ces jeunes
filles on est haute et rafraîchissante
qui rassemble aussi les critiques
médiatiques et du public au public saint
quentinois cette fois de se laisser
embarquer flamme est à voir au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 17 au 20
octobre
merci mélanie à suivre après ce journal
votre émission hebdomadaire le 7-8
culture